so you know Darman we've covered Darman
remember that [__] playing thing that
we covered yeah okay remember Lily Singh
you wanna know what she's doing
oh no she's in Darman videos
how the mighty have fallen what uh-huh
yeah check it out well she's in the new
Muppets thing too yeah no I know just
not just that she went back to Canada to
do Canada's Got Talent uh-huh that's
what she's doing now bro not just that
she also does a game show now called
Battle of the generations that no one
else will watch because it's Canadian
talk about she she had a show on NBC
dude she had the show right after the
main show right oh no it was the after
after and remember she was spearheaded
by the new CEO of Twitter
her show
oh my God we forget about that oh my God
that's right about that yeah it's all
coming together by the way people don't
watch Canada's Got Talent for her it's
Trish Stratus that they're watching it
for sure I hope she's cutting better
promos on there than she is on [__]
wrong take your tits out did you see her
yeah yeah I've seen other promos where
she's like I paved No One China did
China paved the way calm down shut up
like man she in harm Harmon
Lily is that you every Indian to me like
man uh
is this gonna be a dick thing yes oh
I remember because he's a bisexual woman
of color
hey better Dice and a couple things am I
right
I want you to look at me unironically
yes yeah of course
did you not hear what I said no
no she's on she's autistic it keeps her
calm I said move get out of my way Curry
tits
listen here you Packy [__] yeah go back
to your [__] country and go get
ganged you [__] [__] I'm gonna
give you a butter chicken beat down yeah
don't you have an arranged or a chicken
don't you have an arranged marriage to
be at you stupid [__] I know what
you're not eating a hamburger yeah why
don't you go back to India dump some
more plastic into the ocean piece of
[__] go eat with your hands you [__]
animal
I think this we're going to be meaner
than whatever
I don't know where any of that came from
don't you know girls aren't supposed to
wear their hat backwards what year is
this what planet is this what's
happening
that's even if they wear hats at all you
know you should be interested yeah
you're here for once yeah and then maybe
it wouldn't look so
Also let's be fair she deserves a stream
and not because she's Indian but because
she's a Red Wings fan oh yeah yeah
teacher Detroit come on yeah I'll try
that right after you guys stop being so
mean for once
nobody talks like this then maybe you
wouldn't be so ugly nobody talks like
this nobody
where's Lily inside that is Sloan that's
not Lily Singh that's her story first of
all how long do we get to watch these
[__] 30 year old high school women
arguing something you want or are you
just crowding me you're supposed to be
high schoolers look at the blonde yeah
that woman's 36 yeah she's three kids
she has three kids no reason you know
this is our table go find somewhere else
to sit Jesse there's literally Empty
Tables everywhere are you blind well it
sounds like you have one no but I can't
Pan the camera the other way because
this is clearly a set
idiot good catch idiot
a lot of options then
bye we couldn't get somebody a little
younger and a little better looking to
play high school girls no
it really does look like if Britney
venti had the Bane juice yeah you got
the bangers
say you think grifting is your ally
I was born to it I was ambushing Alex
Stein before you were already a man
that's gonna say I was doing the SIM
card because I was a boy
I feel like they were all arguing and
there's a lot of space why is this
Indian [__] dressed like Al from step
by step I don't know but great for each
frame yeah
who's fighting over space in this
lunchroom it seems It's so empty
oh
whoa are you big guys being so mean to
Pinder [__] let's go back to Seek and
Destroy over here that's the the guy
with the teleporting guy from punch out
right you know you're thinking of of a
was it a tiger tiger tiger tiger tiger
yeah King Tiger King Tiger Tiger there
oh okay so this is Tiger Ali sing then
yeah yeah yeah or is it dolphin
there's only a few famous Indian people
especially from our generation yeah
aren't you going horrible I don't get
you know these typical Bollywood
elitists you know I'm so [__] sick of
this I'm sick of the [__] oh I spy
says it
I think learning how to pronounce a
made-up word is the least to your
problems right now uh what could
possibly be worse than me messing up the
lyrics to the song I'm rapping in front
of the entire star man ah yes is their
origin story School uh remember Darman
started all this Darman before he was
this he got in huge trouble for fraud
for an illegal like [__] weed yeah
like big time what's work like a weed
like a company is what Mom Dad are gonna
do to you after you talk who watches
this [__] though it's just so it's like
almost like chat gbt generation 18.1
million people do
unbelievable and I'm not just talking
about you rapping in the talent show
either
[Music]
they're not you know Mom and Dad have a
ranged husband for you you cannot be
looking at women
gonna be happy
well
why are you not eating because I'm
waiting for Mom
that's not fair you should be sitting
here with us eating and not cooking well
then how are we going to eat if
somebody's not cooking someone's got to
cook
actually I have a better also what are
we another weird dilemma that never
happens right like if you're cooking
right you can wait a few minutes you
wait till every all the foods and you
eat together it's fine I can wait a
couple minutes yeah
maybe we can have Dad and Seth B cook
for us while you sit next to me mine you
eat and then he just starts beating the
[__] savagely face her the dad grabs
her by the [__] nape of her neck and
he's just face smashing her repeatedly
and then they do an honor killing and
that's how this ends
what up everyone it's your girl Lily oh
there she is
is Lily singing this as Lily saying yeah
she's inspired a generation and by the
way uh maybe you know when I see this
happen with Indians and Asians and all
these people right where they come here
and they build a nice life and then the
next generation of their kids are a
bunch of spoiled little Detroit Red Wing
wiggers lose her [__] [__] lesbian
dicks and maybe if you don't want to be
disappointed in your children and you
want them to honor your cultural history
maybe stay in India maybe stay in China
maybe stay wherever you're at and make
them be a doctor there they're not going
to be listening to ice spice if they're
living in [__] Mumbai
good point we're watching Darman videos
but who's gonna get Lily sing and
Aquafina
[Music]
what is that
oh that's that's a talent show the
releasing hosts now in Canada
nice job Alex why hey maybe next time
you can make my ex-boyfriend disappear
oh
hey okay don't worry I think as long as
you keep your weight up that high
managed you're gonna have no problem
disappearing boyfriends yeah you'll be
all right Jesus Christ you made the
[__] tired cheesecake disappear you
fat [__] part this song is appropriate
to be singing yeah I took out all the
swear words
that's not what I'm talking about what I
mean is are you sure this song is
appropriate for a girl to be singing
what year is it you know maybe you
should stick with one of the nice songs
like the one Sloan is doing you know the
Spice Girls yeah I believe the rapping
to the boys
literally cardi B Nicki Minaj Megan the
stallion like there's a bunch of
femalese brown just makes nobody took
him the brat Queen Latifah I mean it's
salt and pepper what are you talking
about we've had female rappers as long
as there's been rap but every doorman
bit is this it's always a made-up
dilemma that never happens like hey why
don't you leave rap into the the men and
it's like this just so many female
rappers
yeah they literally when Meek Mill and
Drake were beefing Drake wrote a song
Because Meek Mill was dating Nicki Minaj
at the time and he literally said is
that a world tour or your girl's tour
that's funny and that's a good and by
the way that's a good line and the other
line which was uh shout out to all my
boss [__] wife and yeah there you go
it was another good [__] line
all right next the Lily Lily Singh was
born in 1988. based supposed to be in
high school right here
okay so it's like assuming she's 16 here
it's [__] 2004. that's not Lilly
Singh no they
is that supposed to no it's a different
name it's even Lily
no I thought it was supposed to be their
origin story don't have time no it's not
too lighting of their Origins I've
already made up my mind
I'm dropping out of the talent show
tomorrow nobody cares it's a talent show
for high school it's completely
worthless it's not affect your future in
any way there's [__] no Stakes uh-huh
yeah are you gonna go against the kid
that just learned how to do a magic
trick wrong no not only did I not
practice but Mom
girl thing they'll get over it trust me
trust me Darman says to disobey your
parents because he's a YouTube guy
disobey them I'm annoyed at your little
like Audi belly button hat yeah really
bugging me remember when they stopped
talking like the end of a [__]
balloon animal that's it exactly for
months when I didn't get into honors
algebra my freshman year
it didn't last forever eventually they
started talking to me wow what great
Exposition you got into honors geometry
what's honors geometry geometry's
geometry geometry yeah oh yeah when you
start getting to like you know 10-sided
shapes 15-sided shapes gets crazier they
show you the secret Pythagorean theorem
yes oh
look
my point is I don't think you should
drop out especially considering I have a
big surprise for you who is this guy and
why won't we go away
you know you're actually a good brother
no he's not but I don't think Sloan
wow what a small weird little town
center give it back
right now oh you hear that girls there's
none of this she's not in hot mood
hopefully she learns how to say it right
before she goes on stage and humiliates
herself what the [__] I'm dropping out
also what are you I'm sorry stop stop
everything here I hate applying logic to
these [__] things but it drives me
nuts
so she's trying to rap a song that
already exists
for a talent show in a high school
so and she can't pronounce one of the
words just listen to the [__] song
that's easy it's not like you're reading
lyrics and you don't know how to
pronounce something it's already a song
you dumb [__]
and oh God I hate all I'm sorry I'm so
angry at all of them
not to come
it's a girl suit woman oh God she's back
again ew a couple things Lily you're
getting ridiculously fat because that's
why you're wearing these baggy clothes
because you're getting fat and we all
see it and you think you're hiding it
but you're not hiding it okay yeah you
can you can dress like vanilla ice all
you want it's it's not hiding anything
yeah well you you you're wearing turn of
the century pajamas with a backwards cap
what are you doing you look like you're
a member of Third Base yeah [__]
seriously
[Music]
nobody would be that impressed yeah you
mean Lily seeing you're the one that
took over for Carson Daley and then lost
that gig you can walk in there you can
walk into a [__] Panera Bread at four
in the afternoon in Toronto and running
Lily saying nobody cares nobody cares
doing here I told you I had a surprise
how the [__] did well eyes the surprise
would be not having Indian food for
dinner this is a whole different level
hey aren't you former NBC personality
Lilly Singh
luckily he's good at keeping a secret
um
yeah but not at convincing her ah
Jesse decided to drop out of the talent
show even though I told her so many
times not to what no no you can't drop
out trust me it's not what I want but
literally disowned me
listen they're your parents and honestly
I just think that maybe I should go be a
doctor I don't want to get an
entertainment because what you've done
for Indian women has set us back so far
in the entertainment industry that
they're never going to give a woman like
me a show ever so thanks for that
you sooner or later I know mine did
here's the trick to Indian parents okay
you just gotta keep hey Lily's saying
well anyway where's my doordash order
that's what both producer Brody said
eating their Roti and they'll get over
it fast every everything is Indian this
and Indian that but if you make a joke
you're a racist no [__] these people you
know and Hank is there is not doing a
[__] apology tour saying he hurt so
many people by doing a [__] area and
die [__] loser no matter how much you
made all did you give the money back did
you give all the money back for being a
poo huh did you give it back I didn't
think so right Hank so why is this like
revisit visionist history that they're
like wow what an offensive stereotype
these characters were and it's like they
were beloved characters
immigrant that came here opened a
business and assimilated yeah what the
[__]
he was washing his T-bird in his jean
shorts surgery police
he was the most American character that
was the whole point of the [__] car
and now they just go back and go the
accent was offensive no it was pretty
spot on foreign
er's Cuban accent don't get [__] mad
about Hank Azaria hey Tony how are you
doing your parents put too much butter
too totally first off no such thing
but it's not just my parents it's the
people at school people online I just
feel like everyone's against so you just
like show up to high schools Lily you
just like walk in
me yeah I know the feeling I mean that's
exactly how I felt when I started making
videos wait also also the school has
like a white picket fence yeah and she
could just park your car right up to the
front of the like right to the wall of
the school only one car park there it's
just man it's a Tesla since it's an
indoor Studio you can't have a
gas-powered vehicle because the carbon
monoxide nice product placement
really you felt the way I feel but
you're Lily saying
killed [__] loser
you have millions of subscribers and you
have millions of subscribers but
surprisingly you couldn't convert them
over to your TV show really really it's
almost like you were Astros turfed on
YouTube and really didn't have the
following you thought you had no and
then what little following you did have
when you went to NBC you started
neglecting your YouTube channel and then
they started resigning you really just
seems like it made a whole big pick the
whole bouquet of whoops and daisies and
also what is this [__] but you have
millions of subscribers could we just
stop equating value as a human of how
many [__] followers you have yeah
anyone who thinks that way just end it
end it off yourself bro she has 14
million Subs her last video that came
out five days ago only has 100K views
that's not good that's bad so what
you're telling me Virg is that she has
14 million subs and she was born in 88.
oh based not always in the beginning I
still have a call back
yeah a lot of hate comments to be honest
I get a lot of hate comments and most of
these revenge of the CIS guys they're
[__] in my algorithm every time I put
a video up they have not been nice
honest
I still do and apparently even I have
less connections at YouTube than Chris
Cuomo because I never they never got
removed from that part of the algorithm
I never really thought of that so I had
a girl go with it you're a girl and
girls are stupid there's the answer fish
bulb yeah stop being stupid stupid the
only way there is to deal with it
by crying and then getting people's
channels taken down buying progressively
larger pant suits and I mean they're
getting huge these there's like a 4XL
she's wearing now she's dressed like a
90s stand-up comic yeah no [__]
seriously she's just like uh Public
Enemy
staying true to who I am oh she also has
no Netflix special coming out oh really
another Indian with a Netflix special no
way
every time you go to Netflix comedy
spells you put your [__] Indian dudes
that's all it is it's Indian dudes and
[__] and that's it Nick Mullen said
it was all hot hot chicks or
condescending Indians
like every single one is just them with
glasses like hmm
no matter what because and by the way
Indians aren't funny
I've I've yet to not on purpose an
Indian comic where I go holy [__] rust
mini maybe a little bit he's kind of
wasn't he Indian yeah not a big fan of
Russell Peters oh no that's the one I'm
thinking of Russell please
okay but he's probably the funniest
Indian I can't think of any like a
season sorry no I hate him I'm just
putting up because he's a one-note
[__] wigger act I I've always hated
his answer even when he was like red hot
at the time I always [__] hated him
live your life making someone else happy
sooner or later
they'll cancel your NBC show Reddit
you're right
so so Lily sings Right disobey your
parents does that
mean you just said she just said it huh
she just said this this is what I mean
when Darman has no
the the entire thing falls apart because
the core premise makes no [__] sense
huh
it seems pretty easy dude commercial you
gotta also remember it's not just him
writing this it's also her
all right cool but I don't think you
should do her song yeah just don't think
it's a good idea really no
I feel like you should do something a
little more
White
you
oh my God she gets her powers the same
way the guy from Over the Top does
Hawks [__] or Hawk depending on what
part twice as much strength and power if
she puts the hat backwards
perfect
so you look just like her so just do the
same song with the hat backwards
why all right can I ask something why is
the
why is she doing an I Spy song
and they're doing a [__] Spice Girls
because because Darman is a hack writer
and he thought wouldn't that be funny if
I was doing ice spice and everything
Spice Girls so these high school girls
are singing a [__] 25 year old pop
song Yes Yes instead of something more
current correct I hate Darman right bro
I swear to God Dar man if I'm ever in
the same room with you you're not safe
if I can get if I can get like actual
within grabbing distance of you it's not
going to end well
you have pit stains yeah you have pit
stains and man you're like 37 years old
you actually aged another year while
this video was being made you're now 37.
[Applause]
I love that song what a monster look at
that crop you gotta
you got listen can can we can I can I
make a plea can we stop with the Melissa
McCarthy types you mean fat women well
yeah I I agree with you let me stop
women but I mean fat women who think
they're funny I know it's
okay
um let's give it up I'm gonna eat this
whole foot long Sub in one bite watch
for the girls one more time
[Applause]
spicy
I can't wait to record you
sure pulls a gun out and shoots her in
school
this video enters the school shooting in
advance for my next viral video
next up we have Jessie who is going to
be please tell me she goes out no go out
and do no Vaseline dude huh
that'd be great she goes on does no
Vaseline
her own original song
yes I'm gonna cringe
[Applause]
Lilly Singh wrote this you know damn
well she did
I don't know
oh no
[Music]
hello my name is
by the way can I say
this song I mean I maybe I'm just re
rediscovering my appreciation for it so
good as far as a driving song yeah it's
the best this song gets me so hyped when
I'm [__] driving
it's so good
[Applause]
[Music]
first off [__] your [__] and the clip
you clean
with the secret to keep living in a
world where she feels incomplete
was she scared to come out did she just
come out because then I'm getting it all
on video she dresses like a tomboy with
the backwards hat is cool they just
laugh at that oh she's a fan of Lily
saying she inspires her to be the best
version of herself yeah
sorry the cringe I'm
you ever get a like a muscle spasm but
then it locks up
you know what I mean like that's how my
like I I just cringe so hard it felt
like what the [__] was that we worked
out earlier my back is no I want to
vomit I want to vomit
I live for this level of cringe I can't
take it man oh my God it's so good
no she's a queer Indian girl
she's scared to come out but she'll find
a way to be true too I mean she just
came out you just pouted her in front of
her Indian parents
[Music]
[__] bamboo rods yeah it's gonna be
an honor killing
dreams of a world
wait so you wanted a viral video and you
stopped filming when Lilly Singh went up
there yeah at the high school talent
show but I would think if you wanted the
viral video I'd be the
to be without fear no because they don't
know who it is because is that her mom
is there mom up there her mama too they
both look at you
[Laughter]
a projection of society's degree where
Love Is Love no matter who you are
not even following the beat how do
people watch this on ironically a lot of
them do man a lot of them do 1.5 million
views in 18 hours isn't that doesn't
that worry you oh sometimes when you see
this [__] yeah you consume like in
masses and you're like I don't
see what the like the charm is I I don't
know man
oh she's spinning off the Dome Virgie
how does your brother know the lyrics
he's spitting off the Dome
what do you think's under his hat the
lyrics
she a queer Indian girl I'm proud to be
you've been disowned from the family I
hope it was worth it because of a
YouTube Star told you you will get no
inheritance you will live in shame
that's if they don't kill you on the
family the shame
so all four of them
he won't tell you what you can or can't
do you're beautiful you're amazing just
the way you are that's a lie that
thing's not beautiful or amazing that
looks like a little lizard what are you
talking about you know right side this
pegged a long time ago it really is just
algorithm pleasing God it's exactly what
it is it's whatever's the algorithm you
throw it all together make it positive
and that's it
you'll find your way you'll reach for
the stars keep your head up high and
your heart open wide and you'll find a
place in this world where you can shine
can I be honest
should have done the ice spice I spice
one of it better
but honestly The Spice Girl song was
better yeah but they but they couldn't
do it because uh they're swearing and
Darman can't do swearing oh that's right
Darman sounds like a real [__] queer
Indian
[Music]
[Applause]
that's another thing too how many
Indians watch this
I mean Lily's seeing whenever Lily sing
does something she does have a loyal fan
of Indians it will literally follow her
anywhere because there's not many famous
Indians
of course Indians always stick together
why the [__] do you think we had to deal
with the Great Khali all those years and
I was garbage we had to deal with them
for years for like a decade
how come you didn't work with tiger Ali
Singh no
[Applause]
this should end with the father hanging
himself yes but have the results in just
a moment everyone so there was only two
contestants yes they showed you they
didn't have time to show the other ones
I get it but it's just fun it's like
it's funny to me the only show the two
definitely not gonna be an easy and
she's gonna win Jesse you did amazing
you have to wear that hat everywhere the
thing must stink
no one can believe you got it's like a
reusable diaper it's like a poopy in it
let's show up
whoa this is so cool
I had a lot of fun why
makes one of us figure out how to make
Mom and Dad not hate me after you win
they won't be able to oh that'll make up
for you oh and my wife my my only dream
of having a beautiful normal Indian
wedding is is okay because she did good
at a high school talent contest yeah my
daughter is never going to be married or
bear me any children or grandchildren
but uh hey you won the big talent show
and then they got that should be like if
it was Ice spice that would have even
been fine but it wasn't
thank you
all right the results are in and the
winner of this year's talent show is
the joke would be like a third unknown
person one that we never saw yeah some
some um
some black guy who plays the banjo or
something yeah [__] you know
[Music]
oh [__] A Shyamalan twist
to be fair that rap sucked it was bad
huh
Ma I'm so sorry
you know what you [__] dirty dick oh
here we go before I married your dad
I wanted to be a singer I thought she
wouldn't say she want to be but the
doctor thing like this
what
I didn't even know you saying because I
stopped my mom and dad did not think it
was a good idea for girls to be singing
well now seeing with the way your
daughter is it's probably a great idea
they stopped you another premise
that would never happen it's another
dilemma that never would happen have you
seen Bollywood people don't believe
women oh my God Bollywood is all women
singing what are you talking about the
entertainment business is all women
singing and dancing what are you talking
about I said
wow so if you sing and you dance I don't
know man for a woman that's going to be
an uphill guys hate that guys hate women
I believe them too
but seeing you up on the stage today uh
Forest mommy in the chat says how does
she know she's queer if she hasn't even
had sex because of the [__] backwards
hat dummy and the baggy shirts and the
remember the hockey jersey that's how
you know the first one we do me a favor
put in a hockey jersey and a backwards
cap tell me how you feel yeah probably
like you'd probably feel pretty gross
and if you do stuff just send us
pictures that's fine yeah you know like
whatever even the soft courses even the
sub we don't care that's how we are
because we care about women on this show
we respect women we respect his [__] out
of them this is a woman and this is
respect and we are constantly respecting
women around here no one respects them
more than us I overwhelm women with
powerful respect women tremble with
respect when they're around us
women are terrified at how much I
respect them they are scared they're
like that guy respects they pee
themselves when we walk around because
we respect them so hard we respect them
so [__] hard